it is a scary good time so much good
stuff going on around the valley weather
is going to cooperate we're on a warming
trend as we head into the holiday
weekend and it's nevada day of course
and friday will be nevada day observed
so three day weekend for the kiddos and
and for any state workers so wonderful
beautiful there whoa there we've gotta
take off live local right now beautiful
air quality it'll stay in the good
category today you know those north
winds just do a great scrubbing job
clean all the air out that will last
through today then as we get into warmer
temperatures to finish off the week and
winds are light things get a little bit
hazier lots of 50s around the valley but
we do have some 40s too nellis sunrise
mountain seven hills mountains edge just
just barely into the 40s henderson
you've dropped 49 but as we get these
warmer afternoons the mornings will stay
milder we're going to jump right into
the plains because this is where some
volatile severe weather is happening
right now from kansas through oklahoma
down to texas these are severe
thunderstorm watch boxes and even some
warnings as a line of thunderstorms is
intensifying as it rolls out of dallas
and austin towards houston this morning
and we expected this this is the storm
that hit us on monday the one that hit
california the bomb cyclone on sunday
and it continues to move to the east so
we will expect to hear about
unfortunately some damage from these
thunderstorms if nothing else high winds
flooding and some hail very heavy rain
there and strong gusty winds back into
the west the jet stream is up north a
couple of more storms but not nearly as
strong as what they saw over the weekend
into the pacific northwest while we stay
protected with high pressure good
sunshine and temperatures getting closer
to normal today 74 our normal high is 76
and then we keep climbing those numbers
keep going up 80 degrees on saturday
will be the warmest some clouds saturday
night but those should move on out i
mean it is going to be spooktacular for
the trick-or-treaters beautifully mild
mid to low 70s through the evening hours
for trick-or-treaters and then a few
clouds around us we start off november
next week